He has a very pithy, elegant and,
um, economic, in terms of use
of words, to the point way of
explaining how we learn languages.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
and today, I want to announce my
livestream conversation with Dr.
Stephen Krashen.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
I'm really excited.
I've known Dr.
Krashen for quite a few years.
Uh, I met him for the
first time in Taiwan.
And, uh, so this...
i, I can't remember how many years ago
it was, uh, maybe 15, 20 years ago.
I didn't know who he was.
I attended a language
conference in Taiwan.
He gave a talk there and, uh, I was just
so struck by how elegant, how simple
and how accurate his description was
of the process of language acquisition.
And prior to that, of course,
I had learned languages.
I had been interested enough
in languages to start up LingQ.
I'd done a lot of research.
So I had not only my own experience of
learning languages, but you know, I'm
gonna show you, you know, here all the
different books that I bought on the
subject, because I like buying books.
And there's so much complicated theory
within this whole idea of language
instruction and language learning
and all of a sudden Krashen, Dr.
Krashen he presented, uh...
you know, and I bought
this book in Taiwan.
It's a very thin book,
but it has it all there.
The stages of language acquisition.
And it was, it was clear.
It was like the Gordian knot.
It was like Occam's razor.
It was a simple explanation
of how we learn languages.
It cut through all the other stuff.
Uh, I don't want to get too much into.
Uh, Dr.
Krashen's explanation of the theory
of language acquisition, because
we're gonna have a livestream.
You can see a link in the description
box where you can reserve your spot
and participate and ask questions.
Uh, Dr.
Krashen is very transparent.
You can go to his website uh, I think
it's sdkrashen.com and there's a lot
of free material available there.
But as you know, he, he stresses the
fact that we learn through input.
We learn through compelling,
comprehensible input.
We learn through meaningful messages and
some people may claim that that's not the
whole story that we also have to speak
and that some people, uh, can read and,
and can, can, uh, you know, have high
comprehension, but are afraid to speak.
BUt if people are afraid to
speak, they're gonna be even more
afraid if they don't understand.
So I just feel that everything he
said about language acquisition
matched my experience in learning the
languages that I learned throughout
my first, my professional career.
And then when I got more interested in
languages and when I got very interested
in learning languages, You know, as
a, sort of my third career to start to
focus in on that, I did study online
and of course in bookstores, when
I, you know, 20 years ago, it wasn't
that common to find stuff online.
So I just wanna show you, you
know, so I bought a book, a
short history of linguistics.
Well, that's not quite language
learning, uh, English as a second
language in the mainstream.
Teaching learning and identity.
Like people just wanna learn languages.
Phrases and idioms.
You know, I've talked about this,
don't try to master phrases and idioms.
Uh, but let's see.
Then I even bought a Swedish book
here ... uh, how languages are
learned and on, you know, and, uh, the
practice of English language teaching.
And there was a lot of stuff there that
was quite complicated, got into, you
know, different types of learners, kinetic
learners, oral learners, visual learners,
all of which is not true of course.
Um, I understood very early on that, the
key sort of again, call it the Gordian
knot for measuring where we are in a
language is how many words we know.
Words are key.
with words, you get the rest of
it, you get the grammar, everything
flows from having words and yet...
and so there are many books on
learning vocabulary in another
language, and yet it all boils down...
here again, vocabulary, description,
acquisition, and pedagogy.
It goes...
vocabulary in language teaching.
I read through all these.
And yet it really boils down
to what Krashen says, read and
listen, get the language in you.
Get the brain used to the
language, acquire words.
Naturally, if you do all of these things,
at some point, you're gonna wanna speak.
It doesn't matter when that point is.
Of course you can't be intimidated, but
the better your level of comprehension,
the more words you have at your
disposal the greater likelihood
that you won't be so intimidated.
So, and I, I, I not only is Stephen
Krashen astute in his analysis and
research, this is based on research into
how we acquire languages, but he has a
very pithy, elegant and, um, economic,
in terms of use of words, to the point
way of explaining how we learn languages.
So people are gonna pick holes in some
of the things that he says, people are
gonna have different points of view,
and we welcome different points of view.
And so please join us for this livestream,
whether it is to support what Dr.
Krashen has to say, whether it
be to attack me, which is fine.
I don't mind it.
I love it.
Or whether, uh, to agree with what we
have to say or share your experience
of language learning with us, you're
more than welcome to participate.
We're gonna have a conversation
where we're gonna talk about our
experience of language learning
and, and, uh, talking to people who
are involved in language learning.
I think it's gonna be really interesting.
I'm very much looking forward to it.
Please reserve your spot.
It's gonna be on YouTube
as well as live streamed.
So thank you.
And I look forward to seeing you.
Bye for now.